[Music]
please draw a cute cat on the box with a
speech bubble saying howdy I would like
it to be wearing a cowboy hat I will tip
$10 for listening to my ridiculous
requests this is her butters the pug you
know he's a baller and he wanted
I'd like an extra turkey patty and five
strips of bacon no bun
home pug needs his meat can you please
spell congrats and pepperonis
if the peppers don't fit then use
jalapenos instead can you please also
include a note with the delivery that
says congratulations on your new job
who cares if others get mad you want to
see their faces ever again last time you
guys killed it absolutely awesome salad
I want you to murder that salad with
croutons and Parmesan cheese like I want
it to be offensive to people that don't
like croutons and cheese as much as
you're allowed to throw on there have
people look at that and be like whoa is
that a salad with croutons or croutons
with salad I don't know Rick the
Sunnyside up me Nova had a look here
Morty busier breakfasts people
understand the nature of their eggs if
you just tell them you want over maybe
you'd stop being such a worthless piece
of jays Rick no need to be a jerk about
it I just want the cheese with beef sour
cream and lettuce that's it so if you
could could I just get that dove since
I'm not getting the sauce of jalapenos
and onions I greatly appreciate it and
since I've ordered from you guys a lot
so has my boyfriend because you guys are
the
you
[Music]